all right youtube how the fudge you
doing jake here
we're doing a replay review for our boy
fitz
who is champ two uh champ one champ two
gameplay from mr fitzy here on a 2v2
let's get it bro let's see what this man
can do better
okay easy goal
boom
boom i have no problem with anything
you've done so far
love it good patience all right i know
you don't have a lot of boosts you're
getting it out of your end but
you didn't even need to use boost here
and you just needed your possession away
i don't care how much boost you have
even if you have zero
you control this ball and you flick it
over one defender you are just hitting
this to the other team and giving them
possession that is not bueno okay so
cody
does that
and then goes for boost
i love this game
it even looked like he went in the net
where did he go i'm watching cody now
terrible touch
it's it's not your fault i know you're a
bit confused but you gotta you gotta get
in there and bump this guy
i mean that was actually a really good
grab by gears in here
like good controlled touch to to get it
around you cody should not be going out
of net there but you could have been a
little bit more like right here you
should be like i gotta challenge this
and you can you just drive straight flip
you can you can definitely get in the
way of this you just didn't
so awkward play but you definitely could
have done something there so cody
already i'm less than a minute to this
match
cody seems to be very fast ball chasey
and his 50 50s are bad so far
so already i'm probably deciding in my
head i'm playing defensive
for them for the most part until we see
an opening so we kind of saw this with
lud in the last replay
where you have all the time to take
possession of this ball and i know in
this position it's kind of hard
take your time here guys
i i cannot stress this enough where
people in the champ ranks they just rush
these opportunities
if you just stop on the wall wait for
the ball to get into a position where
you can just jump off the wall and air
dribble it or go off the ceiling or
something this is just panic
and giving the ball to the other team
again so you've already done that twice
in the first minutes i want to say
something here
like
this is just inefficient movement like
if you just want to be more efficient
and get in position faster like just do
this just drive this way
i don't know why you go on the inside
here when the ball is getting cleared
mid
so that's a little odd it doesn't matter
it didn't lead anything but you could
have been a position already to
challenge this ball if you were more
efficient in your movement there you
know what i'm saying i know that's a
small little thing but it could have led
to you not getting losing possession
here they're at least losing pressure
um
got a little lucky i would have liked to
see you go back board here
and make this just so much easier on
yourself
i think you did
yeah stay on backboard just go up the
backboard here so you can hit it like
that could have been a goal
um got a little lucky there but i'm not
super mad about it
good pressure good try
great boost routing love it
fantastic get your get the sauce
oh
let's go fits i'd like to see you turn
around here fitz because you have so
much time to do so
right here
you can literally just turn and get a
facing forward ariel
instead of this
which led to you getting beat to this
ball
it's all about efficient movement bro
where the [ __ ] is your teammate
i'm upset
for you
where did this guy go
all right backwards hit
why
what are you doing
[Music]
brain dead
that's horrible by your boy bro
however
we're not looking at him
you could have avoided the situation
completely with your teammate being
stupid
or i'm saying your teammate was stupid
here shouldn't happen
but
you could have just turned on this made
it so much easier on yourself probably
get a goal here because they're both
right
if you just turned you could shoot this
ball it's wide open
but you did this instead situation could
have been completely avoided now your
teammate stupid
really bad by cody i saw look at this
camera turn chat
look how mad fitz is look at this
boom where's my teammate
can't expect your teammates to
to rotate they just don't what is your
guy doing
this man i don't want to play anymore
i like that clear because your teammate
was not in a good spot
good stuff
okay we're gonna rotate back
really slow but we're doing it
totally fine good job
good pass to cody
cody
yep going for some stupid musky flick
that he doesn't need to
i like this aerial good speed
and not your best recovery ever
i see what you're trying
nice
i love that you didn't go for boost here
that was so good love it fitz
you have been listening
i think you're dead here
holy [ __ ] cody is useless right now
collecting pads like a legend
perfect
uh-oh
good
good demo by cody [ __ ] you're playing
pretty well here man you really are
oh my god cody is
playing horrible
apparently
it's a good play by the other team bro
cody's asleep
cody got a like a bad text from his
girlfriend and he's completely
completely not into this game anymore
you can literally see it you guys notice
that the beginning of the match cody was
flying around everywhere and now he's
like this little slow [ __ ]
that doesn't go for anything
inconsistent gameplay
that's a good play by the other team but
cody's asleep at the wheel dawg so i
don't think you did anything really that
bad there okay so cody's little queef of
a shot here
little sally
shot
not the best
you should notice that right here
and you
turn left and run
but what does fitz do instead
you lingered in the play
just a little bit
then turned flipped
forward instead of sideways to get that
faster flip you did the slow flip then
you did the fast flip you could already
be super sonic here if you did the fast
flip first and potentially gotten back
for this but i mean you gotta right here
bro cody's not scoring this
you gotta get your butt back because
you're not gonna get a pass or anything
maybe you thought you're getting a pass
but
this is a pretty slow rotation bad shot
from your boy but you could have been a
little faster there
free gold
damn
okay
[Music]
yeah
listen
listen bro i can tell you're just mad at
this point you
i would say one minute into this match
should have been
like cody's not very good and i need to
take over
and you just didn't
not gonna lie to you gave a possession a
good amount
and then you weren't really fast on the
rotations where cody just gives up the
ball okay
you were doing the same but i mean
you played a really good game here that
your boy kind of threw but there are
some things you could have done better
that's that's all i can say in this
match bro it is so hard to solo cue this
game at at this point like
honestly i don't think solo queuing's
ever been worse than this season
especially in champ i'm even seeing it
in gc3 it's bad i wouldn't knock
yourself too hard on this game fitz it
wasn't that bad of play from you there
are just some things you could have done
better i wouldn't even say it's up to
that open net like there were just some
touches that could have been better if
you didn't throw away the ball as much
as you did and then
been in a little bit better position
defensively to help your teammate be
useless that's all i really gotta say
with that one dude that's just a tough
tough l you took a tough l it is what it
is